So hello. Hello and welcome.
So welcome to this
very interesting session on real-world data.
It's a mini symposium, and my colleague and myself will be chairing
this session. We will have seven speakers. So my colleague is Dr.
Shivani Sood.
She's Assistant Professor of Radiation Oncology at
University of Chapel Hill. And I'm Dr. Delaloye.
I'm a medical oncologist from Gustave Roussy in France.
So we'll start with a very short introduction, then we will have our seven
speakers. So each speaker will have 10 minutes, and we'll have time for a five
minutes discussion for each. The time is very tight, so we'll
try to do that very properly. And at the end, we'll have a 10
minutes
discussion that will be conducted by Shivani.
So just a rapid introduction to this session, From Real-World Data
to Medicine-Based Evidence. These are my
disclosures. So, what do we build
our knowledge on in oncology right now?
So it looks like this. Based on the crowd of patients,
only seven out of 100 patients will enter
clinical trials and will be the basis of most of
what we derive our knowledge from.
And that's quite
stressful, I would say. And the guidelines are based on clinical
trials plus expert opinion. So expert opinion means us,
the physicians, we do represent the 93
other patients who did not enter the clinical trials.
Of course, real-world data have been very, very important in terms of better
representing
what comes out of these people who do not
enter our clinical trials. So there has been an increasing role
for real-world data in the past 10 years.
Real-world data and real-world evidence, we'll talk about that
later.
Case series, cohort studies, and better and better
methodology allowing us to better understand, better analyze
this real-world data, and especially AI, and we will see several examples,
has dramatically increased our ability to use this real-world data to
build better new knowledge, new tools, et cetera.
Well, there are very important aspects when we speak, of course, about real-world
data. The quality issues is always something
very important. Quality of the data, and you all know about the
garbage in, garbage out. The quality of the methods, the
quality of the reporting are critical.
So there are some guidelines that we might use regarding that.
But until now, it has been a bit disappointing.
The impact of the evidence that we draw from real-world
data has been limited so far. So how can we move forward?
And we will use these example, these seven very nice examples that we
will have today to think about that.
How can this be really transformative?
So there are major fields of interest from real-world data that
we all know. Descriptive epidemiology, understanding the needs
and what is the reality, especially among more diverse population.
We'll have some examples about that.
Prognostic and prediction, it's really important.
Real-world effectiveness is a bit
tougher
of treatment strategies, and cost of care, we don't have anything on cost
today. There are newcomers that are very interesting, newcomers that
are pure product of real-world
data. And I would mention AI-based
biomarkers, which are so important and very rapidly
developing.
Well, to turn the tide by using smart
technologies and produce highly reliable, actionable,
timely, new evidence is critical.
By the use of AI or other methodology to facilitate
data collection, cleaning, analysis, integration,
harmonization, and smart statistical and
AI methods, careful design, sensitivity analysis,
external controls, et cetera. This is very, very
critical. So we will look at our seven abstracts,
have the discussions, and an overall discussion at the end.
Thank you very much. So,
Shivani, up to you.
All right.
So our first speaker is Dr. Emma
Longshore from Biodesx, presenting on a real-world
analysis of non-small cell lung cancer variant level
frequencies from liquid biopsy testing in diverse US
populations.
Just click on start.
Okay, perfect. Today, I have the pleasure of speaking to you about real-world
analysis of non-small cell lung cancer variant level frequencies from liquid
biopsy testing in diverse US populations.
Here are my disclosures.
Biodesx operates across diagnostic and development services with the intention of
transforming patient care and improving outcomes through timely and accessible
personalized diagnostics. In this talk, I will be reviewing consolidated
data from our diagnostic services arm of the business, specifically IQ
Lung Testing.
Lung cancer is one of the most urgent public health challenges in the United States
and touches nearly every community and demographic group.
It is also the leading cause of cancer-related mortality in both the United States
and worldwide. Despite steady improvements to early detection and
treatment, more patients will still die from the disease in one year than colon,
breast, and prostate cancers combined.
And the uneven burden of lung cancer motivates the need for large real-world
genomic data sets that reflect community care.
There are two different primary subtypes of lung cancerThe first being small cell
lung carcinoma, SCLC, which makes up about 13% of
cases. The other is non-small cell lung carcinoma,
NSCLC, which equates to about 77% of cases, will be the topic
of today's talk.
This study assess real-world data of critical biomarkers known to be associated
with NSCLC, as identified from next-generation sequencing and droplet
digital polymerase chain reaction testing in the community setting in the United
States.
Approximately 350,000 tests were analyzed to produce these variant level
insights. The average patient age in our analysis was mid to
late 60s, aligning with national diagnosis trends.
This alignment suggests that our data set reflects real clinical utilization rather
than trial selected populations.
We see consistent test ordering trends throughout the late 60s to early 70s
range, mirroring the true NSCLC diagnostic window.
Another important insight to note here is not just the average tested age, but the
breadth of age of representation from community practice.
This is important because mutation prevalence may vary with age, particularly
EGFR enrichment in older never smokers and KRAS in younger
smokers.
Importantly, this data set also includes 20 self-reported ethnicity groups,
shown to the right, which gives us visibility into testing patterns beyond
traditionally well-represented populations.
Ethnicity is an important demographic variable in lung cancer because
mutation prevalence, access to testing, and outcomes are not evenly
distributed. This is exactly why variant level real-world data are so
valuable. They allow us to ask these questions at a population scale.
To get into the demographics of our population,
sex is another important stratifier in NSCLC.
Biological men still have higher overall incidence in mortality, but younger women
show increasing incidence, and studies have shown that actionable mutations occur
more frequently in women. Our Genostrat DDPCR target panel data
recapitulate this pattern.
The approximately 20% of lung cancer cases occurring in non-smoker will also
disproportionately affect women, reinforcing the case for reflex molecular
testing regardless of smoking history.
These findings reinforce that demographics are not just descriptive, they actually
predict molecular actionability.
Tissue genotyping as the gold standard diagnostic approach has known
limitations like inaccessibility of tumor lesions for biopsy,
minimal tissue quantity availability, invasiveness and infection risk,
as well as patient stress associated with collection procedures.
On the other hand, liquid biopsy profiling offers unique advantages like near
real-time status monitoring, significantly faster turnaround times,
non-invasive collection, as well as the ability to diagnose disease by capturing
mutations from heterogeneous tumors.
The Genostrat DDPCR test is a liquid biopsy-based, targeted
qualitative LDT that identifies actionable mutations in
NSCLC patients. It's highly sensitive and specific and targeted to
clinically actionable mutations in EGFR, ALK,
KRAS, BRAF, ROS1, and RET genes. The average
turnaround time for this test is 2.6 days from lab receipt to test result
delivery, making it ultra-fast.
On the other hand, our NGS test is another liquid biopsy-based qualitative
LDT, but covers a broad 52-gene
panel. This provides an actionable, comprehensive report
of genetic variations and associated approved therapeutics, which are all essential
for the safe and effective use of corresponding products.
And the average analytical turnaround time for this test is three to four days,
balancing depth with speed.
Robust standardized data management workflows are critical for integrating
high-quality outputs across multiple assay platforms, as seen in DDPCR and
NGS testing.
Our quantitative variant level data from the QX200 and S5 systems
undergo QC before being captured in the BioDustix LIMS, while
qualitative data are recorded within Salesforce.
The intentional separation between scientific data and customer-facing systems
supports compliance, preserves analytical rigor, and enables secure
multimodal data integration across multiple assay platforms.
And the combination of DDPCR and NGS testing results provides a
comprehensive landscape view of variant prevalence in non-small cell lung cancer
over the past 10 years, from 2015 to 2025.
Important to note, our data captures all disease stages, including metastatic,
recurrent, refractory, as well as relapsing presentations.
We analyzed 350,000 molecular tests across 20 self-reported
ethnicity groups.
All of our direct and indirect identifiers were removed prior to analysis, with
geographic information being aggregated.
Prevalence in this case is defined as the proportion of variant-positive results
relative to total tests, with Genostrat DDPCR and NGS being evaluated
separately.
I'll now walk through the results by variant class, SNV, indels, fusions,
CNVs, and DDPCR-specific findings.
When comparing literature reported gene prevalence to our observed rates, it's
important to recognize that many published estimates are derived from enriched
academic or referral bias cohorts.
In contrast, our data set reflects routine community testing across the US without
referral bias. As a result, observed prevalences, while sometimes lower
than literature reports, more accurately represent the molecular landscape
encountered in real-world clinical practice.
Beginning with SNVs, nearly half of our NGS tests returned at least
one SNV, underscoring the molecular heterogeneity of NSCLC in
routine care.
Something important to note here is the broad national coverage.
We see SNV positive results distributed across essentially all regions,
reinforcing that actionable genomic alterations are not necessarily concentrated
to a singular academic or coastal center.
TP53 dominates as expected, and it's important to emphasize that
most TP53 variants are not necessarily actionable, but
instead reflect disease biology and aggressiveness.
Internationally recognized HGVS nomenclature is used here to describe the variants,
including P.? and P.=, which denote a protein
impact is expected but cannot be reliably predicted,
and that no change in the protein is expected, respectively.In contrast to
TP53, KRAS G12C and EGFR
L858R, while lower in overall prevalence, have immediate therapeutic
implications.
Variant level reporting allows us to distinguish targetable subtypes within the
same gene, which would otherwise be obscured by gene-level summaries.
Still, the observed prevalence at a gene level aligns well, particularly for
TP53, validating the accuracy of liquid biopsy in real-world
populations.
On to fusions. Liquid biopsy is uniquely suited for fusion
detection because it captures DNA shed from heterogeneous tumors,
especially when tumor quantity is limited.
This is particularly notable because fusion testing has historically been limited
by tissue availability, while liquid biopsy enables detection even in
geographically remote or resource-limited settings.
CCDC6-RET was observed as the most prevalent
fusion. We also see ROS1 and ALK fusions at
expected but distinct variant level frequency.
Despite their lower overall frequency, the fusion-positive map shows clear national
dispersion, with RET, ROS1, and ALK fusions detected across multiple
regions. These data reflect community-level fusion prevalence,
not referral enrichment, which is often seen in academic cohorts.
While fusions make up a smaller fraction of total tests, they represent some of the
most clinically actionable alterations in NSCLC.
The prominence of CCDC6-RET and CD74
ROS1 highlights how fusion partners and not just the kinase matter.
Importantly, we see multiple fusion isoforms within the same gene pairs,
reinforcing why precise breakpoint annotation is essential.
Variant level reporting matters here because different fusion breakpoints may
affect therapy response.
This map highlights copy number variation positive results, which are often
underreported or missed entirely in tissue-based testing due to sampling bias.
Liquid biopsy provides a global tumor snapshot.
CNVs occur at a lower frequency than SNVs but carry high
biological impact.
MYC gain was the most common CNV, consistent with its role as a driver of
proliferation and poor prognosis.
We also observed gains in CCND1, FGFR1, and MET,
which are all clinically relevant pathways.
These findings demonstrate the value of including CNVs in routine liquid biopsy
panels, even if prevalence appears modest.
The geographic distributions suggest these alterations are a consistent component
of NSCLC biology rather than region-specific phenomena.
And this last map represents positive results from over 340,000
individual ddPCR variant tests, giving us exceptional geographic
resolution and statistical power.
Across the 345,000 ddPCR tests, KRAS
G12C was the single most frequent variant, highly relevant given
expanding inhibitor availability.
EGFR exon 19 deletions in L858R also remain prominent.
ddPCR excels at rapid sensitive detection of known actionable variants,
complementing NGS's broad approach.
And this ultra-sensitive detection is reflected in robust
KRAS and EGFR prevalence. Together with the NGS maps,
this demonstrates how complementary technologies capture both breadth and depth of
NSCLC genomics across US diverse populations.
To conclude, this study provides variant level insights using one of the largest
real-world NSCLC liquid biopsy data sets to date.
Variant level data offers higher clinical resolution than gene-level summaries.
Results highlight the importance of rapid centralized molecular testing, especially
in underserved populations, and our future work will focus on deepening
demographic resolution as the sample size continues to grow.
And I would like to thank my team at BioDexics for their hard work producing this
data, as well as our colleagues at Bio-Rad Laboratories and Thermo Fisher
Scientific. And if you're interested in learning more, you can visit our booth or
attend some of our other scientific presentations. Thank you.
If anyone has a question for Dr. Longshore, please feel free to come to any of the
podium
or the mics.
I'll start with one. You had spoken about droplet digital PCR
as well as next-generation sequencing.
In what clinical scenarios and what research scenarios would you
typically recommend one or the other in the setting of liquid biopsy?
And now as you talk about liquid biopsy and the methods we have available to
us, when do you feel tissue testing would still be of value?
Sure. I think that ddPCR testing is particularly relevant when there's a
rapid turnaround time that's needed, or if you're looking for a particular
clinically actionable variant. This is typically what ddPCR is best at testing
at because it has such great sensitivity levels.
And I think tissue is always a great reflex testing for if you're not able to
see a variant at an expected level or if you're looking for a broader panel.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Could you just tell us the percentage of success of your
samples using NGS and ddPCR? And
also, what about these discrepancies between the expected and
real rate, which are really striking for
KRAS especially, and EGFR, of course?
Yes, absolutely. That's a great question.
Sorry, can you repeat that?
The first one is, what was the percentage of success, technical
success, analytical success?
Yes. Technical success-wise, it is highly successful.
I would say over 90% success rate. We have very few QC failures.
Okay. And discrepancies, what are your explanations
for the discrepancies between the prevalence of KRAS and EGFR
mutations as compared to expected?
And when you
talk about expected, it's mostly tissue representativity.
Absolutely. I think the discrepancies are likely related to cohort
biasOur data reflects a wide-spanning real-world data set.
It's capturing all stages of disease, all types of metastasis,
early-stage disease, versus the prevalence is
typically gathered from clinical trial-based data, where it's a very
specific patient cohort. So it's not unexpected to see a difference in
literature-reported prevalence as compared to observed rates.
Thank you very much. And how representative would you
consider this? That's a big question for real-world data as
well as clinical trials, but how representative of
the general US population, do you have any clue
regarding that?
I think that this is certainly representative of the US population.
We certainly aren't capturing all patients, as you would expect,
but it's different than an academic-biased cohort because, again, we're accepting
all different varieties of NSCLC.
So I would say it's an accurate representation of the population.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
So we now will proceed to our second talk, second
speaker, Dr. Trinh Tran.
Yes. Dr. Trinh Tran. She's a PhD and MPH.
She's a postdoctoral fellow in the Integrative Tumor Epidemiology
Branch, Division of Cancer Epidemiology and Genetics at the
NCI, and she's going to talk about histological
profile of lung cancer in never smokers and
prognostic assessment of non-mucinous adenocarcinoma.
Two talks in one.
Let's go.
Hello, everyone. I hope that everyone can hear me okay.
Yes.
Thank you for the very nice introduction.
And today, I will be talking about our project, which
focuses on histological profile of lung cancer in never
smokers and the prognostic assessment of non-mucinous
adenocarcinoma.
So lung cancer in never smokers is increasingly recognized
as a distinct disease entity compared to lung cancer in smokers.
However, most data that we do have comes from
smoker-dominated populations.
From the data that we do have right now, we know that
adenocarcinoma appears to be the predominant subtypes in
never smokers. Within adenocarcinoma, tumors are
classified based on several histological growth patterns,
and never smokers tend to shift toward of having
more lepidic and acinar growth patterns, while having fewer
micropapillary and solid growth patterns.
However, one key limitation from the previous study, which
focuses on lung cancer in never smokers, is that
they are limited in scale and scope.
That is an important gap because histology remains
central in prognosis for lung cancer.
For non-mucinous adenocarcinoma, prognostic
stratification relies on the IASLC grading
system. This system is defined based on the
predominant growth patterns and the presence of high-grade
patterns. Grade 1 is defined with lepidic
predominant, Grade 2 with acinar or papillary
predominant. Both of these grades have less than 20% of
high-grade growth patterns. For Grade 3, it is defined
with any tumors with at least 20% of high-grade
growth patterns, including solid, micropapillary, and
complex glandular patterns.
In the population that this grading system is
developed,
it is clearly distinct
in terms of the recurrence-free survival across different
grades. And this grading system has also been validated
in independent cohort for overall survival, recurrence-free
survival, and disease-free survival.
However, most of the validation cohorts included a
substantial proportion of smokers, and 13 out of 14
validation studies were conducted in East Asian
populations. And given that the IASLC grading
system is defined by the distribution of
histological growth patterns, and the never smokers tend to
have a higher proportion of lepidic and acinar
growth patterns while having less micropapillary and
solid growth patterns, this distinction can shift
the grading assignment as well as the prognostic
assessment for never smokers. So it is important that we
validate the IASLC grading system in never
smokers.
In our study, we aimed first to characterize the
histologic landscape of lung cancer in never smokers for all
histology. Second, to evaluate the prognostic value of
the IASLC grading in non-mucinous adenocarcinoma.
And third, to develop and validate deep learning-based
models for overall survival risk stratification, still
within non-mucinous adenocarcinoma.
We used two independent cohorts for this project.
The first cohort is the SHOLOC-Lung cohort, which is our
internal cohort. The SHOLOC-Lung is the largest cohort of
lung cancer in never smokers to date, with no restriction on
subtype or stage. This is a
multi-institutional cohort which collected data from patients
across five continents, so it reflects a broad spectrum
of lung cancer in never smokers.The second cohort is
the Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center patients.
This specific cohort focuses on early
adenocarcinoma, including 161
cases of non-mucinous adenocarcinoma.
For this project, we included 844
cases of lung cancer in never smokers from all
histology, from the XELOC Lung for our aim one, and
we included non-mucinous adenocarcinoma from the XELOC Lung cohort,
and the MSK cohort for our aims two and three.
As you can see on the slide, patient characteristics remain fairly
comparable across different cohorts.
For our first aim, we first investigated the
histological landscape of lung cancer in never smokers in the
XELOC Lung cohort. We observed a higher proportion
of adenocarcinoma and carcinoid tumor compared to
previous findings, and we
also observed a lower proportion of squamous cell carcinoma and
small cell lung carcinoma compared to previous findings, which
included mostly smokers. This reflects
the distinct histological landscape in lung cancer in never
smokers.
For adenocarcinoma, within our XELOC Lung cohort,
we observed consistent findings with our previous
studies.
When we looked at the overall survival within the XELOC
Lung all stage cases with follow-up time
censored at 10 years, we did not observe any clear
distinction between the grade one and grade two.
Therefore, we combined these two grades in the Cox
models. And in the Cox models, grade one and grade two
combined show a better overall survival compared to grade three
with a hazard ratio of
0.38.
To make a fair comparison with the MSK data, which
focused on early-stage non-mucinous
adenocarcinoma and a fairly limited follow-up time,
we restricted the XELOC Lung to stage one and two tumors
only and censored the follow-up at five years.
We observed consistent patterns across cohorts
with
grade one and two combined show a better overall
survival compared to grade three.
In the XELOC Lung stage one and two tumor, the hazard ratio was
0.31, and in the MSK cohort, the hazard
ratio was 0.51. Although
statistically not significant, but it may be
likely due to the smaller
sample size.
For our last aim,
I collaborated closely with Dr. Manjoy Saha, a brilliant
machine learning data scientist who will also present
tomorrow morning.
In this aim, we developed and validated
a deep learning model for predicting five-year overall
survival.
Dr. Manjoy Saha used the survival data and whole slide
images from 454 cases
of the XELOC Lung cohort to train the
model to predict five-year overall survival.
And importantly, for the inference phase, we
validated our study in both the XELOC Lung and the
MSK cohort, but the model only used whole slide
images without any survival data, which means that
in clinical practice, we can
directly apply this deep learning model to
predict overall survival.
We assessed the model performance using the
AUC index,
for the Cox model included clinical variables and the
grading system. We compared this against our full
integrative model, which included additionally,
the deep learning risk score. As you can see on the slide
across three validation sets, the model
performance increased substantially, and it is
noteworthy that our clinical variables include
age at diagnosis, sex, tumor stage, and ancestry.
One interesting observation in our findings is that we
observed a subset of grade three tumor,
which was classified as low risk based on the deep
learning model prediction. That's why we wanted to understand better
what the model is looking at. And one pattern that stood
out to us when we look into the distribution of
different risk group by ancestry is that
while the grading system show
broadly similar distribution across European
and East Asian ancestries for the grading system, the
deep learning classification tend to show
a different pattern here. The deep learning model tend
to put the people from East Asian
ancestries into the low-risk group.
And this is interesting biologically because it is well
known that the East Asian populations tend to have
a higher proportion of lung cancer in never smokers.
And also lung cancer in never smokers had a
better overall survival compared to lung cancer in smokers.
So it seems like the deep learning model
picked someSome underlying
histological features from whole-slide images
that track closely the more indolent
tumor biology.
To facilitate the pathologist to interpret our
model
prediction, our colleagues at the NCI
developed a web tool for real-time
visualization, where pathologists
can load a whole-slide image and
overlay the model heat map to
observe different patterns.
So here is a small video demo, which
shows the
different regions in whole-slide images.
The red regions indicate
where the histological features are
closely associated with a higher risk according to the
deep learning model, and the cooler region
is where the model associates with
lower risk.
In conclusion, in this study, we leveraged
the largest lung cancer in never-smoker cohort
and showed that lung cancer in never smokers have a distinct
histological landscape compared to lung cancer in
smokers. We also showed that the grading system still
worked in never smoker. However, it
showed limited separation between the Grade 1 and Grade 2.
And last but not least, our deep learning model showed
potential for survival prediction and complements
pathologist assessment.
With that,
I wanted to say thank you to my team, our
collaborators, patients, and families who make
this research possible. Thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to take any
question.
Thank you. Thank you very much. So this talk is now open for questions.
We have two
to three minutes at most. Come to the microphone.
So I will start with a question, of course.
So do you think the grading in
lung cancer is validated using this data, or do we need more
data, especially registry-based data, instead of more
selected cohorts as you used?
We would love-
Is this a proper validation?
We really would love to have as much data
as possible. But unfortunately,
most data right now for lung cancer specifically does
not systematically collect smoking
status. So it is very difficult for us to depict which
patient has a smoking history or not to really
use registry data to validate the grading system.
Very good point. So that's a major barrier for that kind of
validation. So you have to use selected-
Yeah. So it is a huge effort of my PI and our team
to collect such a large amount of data for lung cancer in never
smokers.
Okay. Very good.
Yes, a question from Dayong Chen.
Yes. I was very intrigued by your data with the deep learning model where
you see the classical grading system doesn't hold true, especially with the
East Asian population. I was wondering, are you able to identify the biology that
your deep learning models are really picking up?
I think that would be good stepping stone to perhaps recalibrate the grading
nomenclature.
It is such a great point. One challenge
for us right now is to interpret which the
model sees in the whole-slide image.
And our
effort to try to depict
to nitty-gritty details of what the model
sees in the whole-slide image is that currently we try to
cross-check with different clinical variables and
molecular data, too. We also
collaborate with pathologists so that they can help us to
observe whole-slide images and compare in cases with
discrepancies between
the grading system and the prediction from
deep learning model. But in terms of the architecture, I
would not say that it's impossible right now, but it is not possible for
us to really understand what the model
uses to make its prediction.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you. Very great.
Very nice talk. So, sorry. We are
really tight on time.
So going to the next talk.
So now we welcome Dr. Zenara Shah from Roseville Park Comprehensive
Cancer Center.
Good afternoon, everyone. On behalf of my co-authors, I'm pleased to present the
findings of our study.
These are my disclosures.
Metastatic colorectal cancer remain associated with poor long-term outcome
despite advances in systemic therapy.
Approximately 80% to 85% of colorectal cancer are
microsatellite stable, a subgroup with limited effective treatment options.
Within microsatellite stable disease, HER2 amplification occur in 2% to
4% of cases and defines a biologically distinct subset
characterized by primary resistance to anti-EGFR therapy and
sensitivity to HER2-targeted agents.
This identifies an aggressive chemotherapy-refractory population in which
targeted therapy may improve
outcomes.Trastuzumab
deruxtecan has demonstrated substantial activity in HER2-positive
metastatic colorectal cancer. In DESTINY-CRC01,
among heavily pretreated patients who had received greater than two prior
lines of therapy, trastuzumab deruxtecan achieved an overall
response rate of 45% and median overall
survival of 15.5 months. However, the role of
trastuzumab deruxtecan earlier in the treatment course remains
unclear. Whether these benefits extend to less heavily pretreated
real-world patients, particularly in the second-line setting, remain an
important unanswered question.
To address this gap, our primary objective was to compare real-world
overall survival between trastuzumab deruxtecan and standard
chemotherapy in patients with microsatellite stable,
HER2-amplified metastatic colorectal cancer.
From a clinical perspective, we aim to answer a key question, whether
trastuzumab deruxtecan improve long-term survival when used earlier
in the treatment course, specifically in the second-line setting.
We conducted a retrospective cohort study using the TriNetX US
network from 2010 through 2025. Cohorts were
defined by the lines of therapy at which patient initiated either
trastuzumab deruxtecan or standard chemotherapy.
Eligible patients were adults with HER2-amplified microsatellite stable
metastatic colorectal cancer. Patient received either second-line
chemotherapy including FOLFOX, FOLFIRI, or CAPOX, with
or without bevacizumab or trastuzumab deruxtecan.
Patients with prior exposure to anti-EGFR or anti-HER2 therapy
were excluded.
Before matching, baseline differences were observed between the two cohorts.
Patients receiving standard chemotherapy had highly higher rates of
comorbidities, including chronic obstructive pulmonary disease and a greater
burden of lung metastasis. BRAF mutations were also
modestly more frequent in the chemotherapy cohort.
Importantly, all patients across both groups were HER2 IHC3
positive.
Prior treatment exposure was otherwise broadly comparable between cohorts.
These imbalance underscored the need for adjustment, which we addressed using
propensity score matching.
Matching variables included age, sex, comorbidities, metastatic
disease burden, and prior treatment exposure.
After matching, excellent covariate balance was achieved, with all standardized
mean difference less than 0.1. The final matched cohort
included 1870 patients in each group for comparative
analysis.
Overall survival was analyzed using Kaplan-Meier with log-rank testing,
and adjusted hazard ratio was estimated using Cox model.
Statistical significance was set at a two-sided P-value less than
0.05, with safety outcome assessed descriptively.
In the matched cohort, early overall survival was similar between
groups with one-year overall survival of 85% for
chemotherapy and 83% for trastuzumab deruxtecan.
Over time, the survival curves separated, demonstrating improved long-term
outcomes with trastuzumab deruxtecan.
At five years, overall survival was 58% with trastuzumab
deruxtecan versus 49% with chemotherapy.
Consistent with these findings, standard chemotherapy was associated with a
higher risk of mortality compared with trastuzumab deruxtecan,
hazard ratio 1.14. Given the early curve crossing, the
hazard ratio should be interpreted with caution.
However, the sustained late separation supports a long-term survival
advantage with trastuzumab deruxtecan.
We observed slightly higher rates of all grade interstitial lung disease and heart
failure than those reported in clinical trials.
Specifically, interstitial lung disease occurred in 12% of patients, while
heart failure occurred in 9%. Importantly, these were
EHR-coded events and were not independently drug adjudicated.
These findings support careful cardiopulmonary monitoring, including symptom
surveillance, interval chest imaging, and echocardiography when
clinically appropriate.
Comparative toxicity profile remained distinct between treatment groups.
Hematological adverse events were broadly similar between treatment groups
including anemia, thrombocytopenia, and decreased neutrophil count.
Fatigue and vomiting were more frequent with trastuzumab deruxtecan.
Diarrhea occurred more often in chemotherapy cohort.
Overall, these findings highlight the need for proactive monitoring of
cytopenias and supportive care when using trastuzumab deruxtecan in
routine practice.
Our study has several important strengths.
We used a large, multi-institutional real-world data set, achieved
well-balanced cohort through propensity score matching, and had sufficient
follow-up to evaluate long-term outcomes, including five-year overall
survival. However, some of the limitations should be acknowledged.
As an EHR and ICD-10 coding-based analysis, there is
potential for misclassification, limited treatment granularity such
as dose modification or treatment intensity, and adverse events that
were not independently drug adjudicated.
In addition, cancer-specific survival and progression-free survival could not
be assessed.
Clinically, these findings suggest that trastuzumab deruxtecan may be considered
a second-line option for patients with microsatellite stable,
HER2-amplified metastatic colorectal cancer.
This result also support earlier integration of antibody drug
conjugates in this population, consistent with observations in other
solid tumors where earlier line use had demonstrated preserved or
improved activity, including DESTINY-Breast09.
Importantly, prospective trials are needed to validate these findings and
define the role of trastuzumab deruxtecan in the second-line
setting.HER2-amplified
microsatellite stable metastatic colorectal cancer represents a high-risk,
low-frequency population with limited treatment options.
In this large real-world cohort, use of trastuzumab deruxtecan in the
second-line setting was associated with improved long-term survival
compared with standard chemotherapy.
With similar early outcomes but clear late divergence favoring trastuzumab
deruxtecan. These findings extend prior Destiny
CRC-01 and Destiny CRC-02 data into an earlier-line
real-world treatment setting.
I would like to sincerely thank my co-author, Dr. Sumbul Aziz, and my mentors, Dr.
Shehla Karbaji and Dr. Kannan Tanikachalam, for their guidance and
support.
We welcome any questions. To
start, you had talked about how the patients were propensity matched on
several factors, including the prior treatment.
Can you elaborate? Was that matching based on the drug?
Was it based on the duration for which they had been on first-line therapy?
So it was based on the drugs. So it was those who have received
FOLFOX or those who have received FOLFIRI, they were matched on that basis.
And then with time, you had commented on the curves initially being very
similar and then separating. What was the estimated
patient sample size as you got out to those longer time points?
So when we were around the longer time points, we still had
around
58% in one cohort and 49% in the other
cohort that were still alive.
Could you just comment some regarding that on the median follow-up, because you've
mentioned a good median follow-up, but we didn't see it.
What is the median follow-up in each cohort?
Because you know it's a very classical bias of that kind of
comparisons that the chemo group may
have a much longer-term median follow-up as compared
to the T-DXd, and it might have an impact on the way you'll be
able to capture the overall survival.
So the median follow-up time was around more than five years.
In both cohorts?
In both cohorts.
Okay. And how many-
And it was decided from the date of index date.
Okay. It would be good to have the numbers under the curve.
Now, well, did you plan any sensitivity analysis?
That kind of approach is comparative effectiveness is something that is
very dangerous. You know that.
Yeah. In future, we are planning to do that.
And it's very touchy. So we need sensitivity analysis like
landmark analysis, one year or two years, et cetera,
to make sure or case controls
matching. That's also sensitivity analysis that might be of interest if you want to
publish this data.
Yes. We plan to in future do more sensitivity analysis, and we also
plan to do restricted mean survival time-
Yeah
... which will be more accurate than the probabilities.
Yeah, and probably divergence would come from hazard ratio
that could be compared in time periods and not just the curves that
are basically...
But yeah. Anyway, very interesting, and I feel it's very
reassuring to see what this overall
survival is-
Yes
... in this cohort anyway. Any other comments, questions?
Sure. I'll give one more.
So as we look at the data that you've presented here, and then we think about the
clinical translation, what further evidence do you
feel is needed
before that point? And it's interesting you had talked about how this
looks at a cohort
that is being treated earlier, which implies that in the clinic, people have
moved to offering T-DXd earlier, even though
the Destiny data was in later lines.
So what further evidence do you think is needed, and what do you make of the
clinical trial data being perhaps discrepant with what we see in practice?
Yeah. Sure. That's a very nice question.
So, as we know that in clinics, they know from other
solid tumors that antibody-drug conjugates when are used in front line,
they have better responses. And in colorectal cancer
also, they know that with chemotherapy given either FOLFOX
after FOLFIRI or FOLFIRI after FOLFOX, they do not have much response.
So antibody-drug conjugates we know have more response
as compared to chemotherapy because they deliver the targeted
drug. So that's why this is hypothesis
generating, and we need a prospective trial in which the drug is tested in
second-line setting. For example, in
breast cancer, the antibody-drug conjugates have moved from
second line to first line, and now even in neoadjuvant setting.
So I think we have to take the same knowledge and take to
GI cancers and move ADCs to upfront.
Great. Thank you for your presentation.
I had just-
Sorry.
A last small question. That's the problem with being ahead.
You have more questions because we need to stick to time.
Well, my question is, in clinical trials, we have this big problem of
crossovers that are not possible.
And finally, in real-world data, crossovers are often,
well, rarely made. So do you think this data might be of
interest to test whether a crossover
of T-DXd might have the same impact on the long term?
That's a very critical question.
Yes, but it won't be possible to do with the real dataset because there are a lot
of limitations of the real-world dataset.
Okay. Well, next time.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for answering our tough questions.
Thank you.
So it's now time for our next speaker, Dr.
Caroline Hilbert, who is Assistant Professor in the Department of
Population Health Sciences at the University of Utah
and the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
She's going to be talking about cancer risk with initiation of
angiotensin receptor blockers versus
angiotensin-converting enzyme inhibitors.
So we are switching
from metastatic cancer to risk prediction.
Very nice picture.
Thank you. They always ask us to put that in there, so move to Utah, yay.
Yeah, thank you so much for having me. Thanks for the lovely introduction.
As mentioned, I'm going to present some work on cancer risk with
initiation of angiotensin receptor blockers versus
angiotensin-converting enzyme inhibitors using a target
trial emulation.
Can I just
use the mouse?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Okay. No financial disclosures.
So just to give a little bit of a background, we know that hypertension is
a major public health burden. There's a high prevalence, and we see an increased
prevalence also among
the younger population, leading to a longer
exposure of antihypertensive drugs among this
population. And so there is an increased interest in identifying the
long-term effects of these medications on the general
population. ARBs and ACE are first-line
therapies, and they're really clinically interchangeably used.
They're both effective for cardiovascular disease prevention.
They're currently prescribed among over 40 million
US adults. On the right side, you can see they both act on
the renin-angiotensin system, the R**S system.
ACE acts higher up,
inhibiting the transformation from angiotensin 1 to angiotensin 2,
while also leading to an increase in accumulation of
bradykinin. An ARB, on the other hand, acts much lower in
the signaling pathway, inhibiting the
AT1 receptor, but really leaving the AT2 receptor signaling
alone.
So what is currently known about
the risk of cancer with these medications?
Overall, the evidence is inconclusive.
Most of the studies have been done more in stromal cancers, including lung,
renal, and also GI cancers.
And a lot of the studies have been limited in small sample sizes, case-control
designs, and residual confounding, especially on
comorbidities.
And just on the right side, showing what the general hypothesis is of
these medications, indicating that ARBs have more of an
antiproliferative and proapoptotic effect, while
ACE are more proinflammatory and are meant to be
proangiogenic.
And so our objective was here to conduct a target trial emulation
aimed to compare the risks of cancer diagnosis and mortality between
ARBs and ACE initiators among US veterans with
hypertension. We leveraged data from the
VHA, which is a large longitudinal prospective
cohort study. About 99 million US veterans
are included, receiving care at the VA.
On the right side, you can see that
it's really rich electronic health record data coming from VA
facilities, community providers, military health systems,
pharmacies, and lab and testing. For our
project here specifically, we used data for the exposure
assessments of the medication on the outpatient pharmacy dispensing
data. So whether a patient filled the
prescription, but then also looking at the outcome
in the VA cancer registry and also death records.
So I'm going to walk you through the target trial emulation
framework. Looking at the eligibility, we had veterans
included with hypertension initiating either of the drugs,
so ACE or ARBs, but not at the same time.
Early 2000 to 2017.
And we emulated the randomization using inverse probability weighting.
And in this large EHR data set, we had 66
baseline confounders available to account for.
Follow-up was from treatment initiation until cancer
diagnosis, death, loss of follow-up, or 10 years, or the end of
study, which was 2022.
And for outcomes, we looked at a comprehensive set of outcomes to follow
a competing risk framework. We looked at
cancer diagnosis, where death was the competing
event, diagnosis-free mortality, where cancer was the competing event,
all-cause mortality, and then a composite outcome of cancer diagnosis and
diagnosis-free mortality.
Statistical analysis were really mainly conducted by
Daniel Addo, who's a PhD candidate in our department,
who's about to graduate, so if anyone's looking for a postdoc.
We computed cumulative incidence, risk ratios, risk differences at
various time points up to 10 years,
and also looked at cancer subtypes by the SEER
subgroups, and also obesity-related cancers,
and also were able to look at various potential effect
modifiers.
On the right side, just some statistics of our study population.
There were 2.6 million US veterans included in this
study. Mean age was about 63 years.
We had 10% ARB initiators and 90%
ACE initiators, and about 17% current smokers and a BMI
of over 30.
Over 10 years follow-up, we had over 280,000
incident cancer cases. Most of them were diagnosed at an earlier stage.
And as you can imagine, this population is predominantly male.
About 95% were male.
And so, as expected, the most common cancers were prostate,
lung, and GI cancers.
Overall, our results show that ARB
initiation was linked to a lower cancer risk.
On the right side, you see the cumulative incidence curves, the dotted
lines indicating the diagnosis-free deaths.
As a reminder, that was where cancer was the competing event.
And incidence cancer
diagnosis in the solid lines. Red indicating ACE
and ARB
in blue.
In relative comparisons, we observed a 20% to 25% lower risk.
At the same time, we did not observe any
major differences in diagnosis-free mortality reallyNot
indicating a early excess risk of death in
this population.
So again, to summarize, lower cancer risk among ARB initiators
without adverse differences in overall mortality.
Subgroup findings, we generally didn't see
any differences across subgroups and also not major differences across the
cancer subtypes. But we did observe stronger effects
among older adults, especially over the age of 70.
Here is just a snapshot of the results at the 10-year time point.
And you can clearly see over the age of 70, where we observed a 30% decreased
risk.
Some strengths and limitations. We had a really large sample size from the VA,
over 2.6 million, and combined a target trial emulation,
really strong methods with a competing risk framework.
Some limitations, residual confounding remains a concern,
and also limited generalizability.
As you imagine, this
data set is driven by having access to
the VA as a healthcare system.
So to summarize, ARB initiation was linked to a 20% to
25% lower risk of cancer diagnosis,
and we observed stronger effects among older adults.
We saw consistencies across cancer subtypes indicating that
biological mechanisms that are underlying this observation
might not be limited to a single organ, but rather
apply to multiple cancer types.
For the clinical impact, the results can
inform the choice of
antihypertensive drugs based on someone's cancer risk.
But more mechanistic studies need to be done, and also studies
informing the first-line antihypertensive therapy
selection.
And with that, I would like to thank especially Daniel Addo, who
conducted a lot of the analysis, all collaborators at
University of Utah, University of Pennsylvania, and Colorado, Adam
Bress's lab, and our funding sources.
And I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Another very interesting talk.
Open to questions. Come to the microphone, do not hesitate.
I think we'll start with our questions.
Of course, when you see that, you
just think of what are the reasons that it might not be true.
And so you told that you had 66
adjustments, and what about residual confounding?
What about communications? What are the reasons for the choice of
one treatment versus the other that might have an impact?
Beta blockers, aspirin.
Well,
because we did not see them, and we did not see the differential
effects in different cancer types.
It's also quite strange that the effect is true throughout
all types of cancer. Maybe it does not exist for any
other drug. That's the big question, yeah.
Yeah, this is a great question.
And I wish I had enough time to show all the-
Of course
... the data we had.
We were able to include lab testings and also other medications that
patients were taking.
With residual confounding, we didn't have data on
cancer diagnostics, like diagnostic testing that was
especially going on early on in the follow-up.
Screening versus no screening.
Mm-hmm.
We did include screening,
to
the best of our methods we could do.
Especially for breast cancer screening and prostate cancer, we included.
But
yeah, there's definitely a risk of
residual confounding. I think we covered a lot of the confounders that
are strong.
66 is a lot.
Is a lot, yes. And it goes from comorbidities to
lab results,
to medication use
as well.
Right.
And geographic differences we accounted for as well.
But just one thing about your different
availability. We are doing sensitivity analysis looking at
when ARBs became more generically available, about
2013, early 2010s.
Yeah.
So we're looking at differences in that effect as well,
when health insurance wouldn't necessarily cover
that. Yeah.
No, no, you had a strong methodology as well.
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead.
Hi. Thank you for the great talk. This is really a very important study.
I just have one question. Is that, we all know that ACE inhibitors came
first and ARBs came later in the practice.
So, did you consider the time differences?
And what if the patient take ACE inhibitors first and
then switch to ARB?
Yes, great question. So, one of the things we're doing the sensitivity
analysis where we're looking at differences in
prescription trends, when it was becoming
more generically available. And then, this one,
these results are showing the per protocol, and we're working on the
intent to treat.
Sorry, these were the intent to treat.
We're doing the per protocol analysis,
where we're looking about on the adherence and accounting for
that as well over time. We did see about 50% were still taking
the medication or after five years.
Mm-hmm.
So we have that data available, but we're working on that analysis to
also to see crossover, as we previously mentioned.
But yeah. Good question. Thank you.
All the same questions.
But it's quite striking that your effect is absolutely opposite to
aspirin. You remember, the ASPREE trial and all data on
aspirin.
Mm-hmm.
Aspirin increased the risk of cancer and of cancer mortality.
The later you started the
aspirin, the more risk of increased risk you had.
Mm-hmm.
And what is currently admitted is that if you want to start aspirin
as a preventive drug for colorectal cancer, start before age
50.
Mm-hmm.
And here is the absolute opposite.
The effect is stronger. So what are your
underlying biological explanations?
And do you think we need... Well,
how-Can we go further? What to do?
Yeah. Are you referring to the age differences that we saw?
Yeah.
So with the RAS system, there is literature showing that the
effectiveness decreases with changes in age-related changes to the
RAS system. So that's what we think would underlie that
observation.
As to further studies,
as mentioned, this is predominantly male-
Male, of course
... and driven by the VA. I think replicating
this in another real-world data set that's
more inclusive,
I think could show more robust
results.
Thank you. Thank you very much for a very good data gate.
Thank you.
All right. Next we have Dr. Emily Peiying
Lin from the Taipei Medical University and Vanderbilt
University Medical Center.
She'll be presenting on assisted reproductive technology and the risk of
female sex hormone-related cancers.
Thank you for the opportunity
to present our study, Assisted Reproductive Technology and the Risk of
Female Sex Hormone-Related Cancers.
I'm Emily Lin from Taipei Medical University and Hospital, Taipei,
Taiwan, and also Vanderbilt University Medical Center, Nashville, Tennessee.
So I have no disclosures.
And the key question of this study is whether
assisted reproductive technology treatment is associated
with the risk of female sex hormone-related cancers.
And why is this question so important?
We will start with the demographic cross.
So demographic cross happens when the
birth rate is lower than the death rate, and
it is so important to society. And demographic cross
has happened in more than 50 countries nowadays.
For example, in Germany, it hit this cross
in 1972. In Japan, it hit this cross in
2005. And in Taiwan, we hit this cross
in 2020.
And because of the low birth rate, our government has
launched a series of policies, including the ART subsidy
policy, to stimulate the birth rate.
And as you can see here in the table, starting from
2015 to 2025, we have already
had three versions of ART subsidy policy in
Taiwan. And you can see here that from
version one to version three, the eligibility criteria has
broadened and the coverage has expanded.
The overall goal is to stimulate birth rate, and it
is estimated that nowadays in Taiwan, one
in 10 babies born every year is through ART.
So since ART was first introduced 40 years ago and since the
first IVF born baby in
1978,
there has been a substantial increase in the utilization of
ART in the past decade.
The percentage has doubled in the United States and tripled in the
EU and quadrupled in Taiwan.
In 2022, the percentage of birth
via ART was about 2.6% in the United
States and 6.4% in the EU and
8.2% in Taiwan.
However,
there has long been concerns about cancer risk with
ART because ART involves intense exogenous
hormone exposures and there are concerns about potential risk
for female sex hormone-related cancers, for example, breast
cancer, ovarian cancer, and endometrial cancer.
Per 2024 guideline of the American Society for Reproductive
Medicine,
there is no association between fertility drug use
and breast cancer, and there is no conclusive evidence
indicating an increased risk of ovarian cancer or endometrial
cancer.
However, although most studies suggested no
risk association between ART treatment and breast cancer,
there was a Danish cohort
published in Human Reproduction in 2021,
reported a positive risk association.
And regarding ovarian cancer, although
most of the studies attribute the increase of ovarian cancer risk
to infertility and parity,
there was a Nordic cohort study published in British Journal of
Cancer in 2022,
reported heightened risk among women who gave birth after
ART as compared to natural conception.
And as to the endometrial cancer, there's indeed no risk association
reported up to now.
So as this is an important question to all the women
and their family, and there's no conclusive evidence yet,
so we conducted this study.
The primary objective is to investigate whether
ART is associated with the risk of breast,
ovarian, or endometrial cancer.
This is a nationwide population-based cohort study in Taiwan
using the linked health datasets.
In this study, a total of four databases were used.
The first one is the Taiwan National Health Insurance Research Database.
In Taiwan,
our national health insurance program covers nearly
99.9% of the population in the country.
This says in this research databaseAbout
99% or more than 99% of the health
data are included.
And the second one is the Taiwan Artificial Reproduction database.
By law in Taiwan, all the
ART procedures,
no matter if it is self-paid or it is insured, has to be
reported to this ART.
And the third one is the registry for catatrophic illness patients.
So with this registry, we can assure that the
diagnoses for cancer are precise and accurate.
And the fourth is the cause of death registry.
So by integrating data within these four data sets, we
build up our ART cohort.
Our ART cohort includes females aged 40 to
70 years old on the data cutoff date, which was
December 31st, 2022.
In our ART cohort, all the women received
ART between 2000 and 2021,
and none of them had a history of breast cancer or
ovarian cancer, or endometrial cancer prior to the index
date.
And the index date here was defined as the
date of first ART.
For comparison, we also built up the non-ART cohorts from
the NHRD.
And the way we built up this cohort is by propensity score
matching at a one to one ratio.
The characteristics considered for matching included age,
comorbidities, family income, urbanization, and
childbirth history.
The cohorts were followed starting the index date.
The index date
was the date of the first ART in the ART
cohort and the match date in the non-ART
cohort.
All the study subjects were followed
until the occurrence of the events, which were
breast cancer, ovarian cancer, or endometrial cancer.
And the primary outcome of this study is cancer incidence.
Incidence of breast, ovarian, and endometrial cancers through
December 31st, 2022, were ascertained.
We used Cox proportional hazards models to estimate hazards for cancer
associated with ART exposure. Those models were adjusted for
age at the
start of follow-up, comorbidities, urbanization,
and childbirth history.
So as you can see here in this table, in each of our
cohorts, the subject number was about
105,000,
and the mean maternal age was 47 at the date
of data cutoff.
And in each cohort, about 5% of the patients had
SLE, Sjögren syndrome, or rheumatic arthritis.
About 2% had Hashimoto thyroiditis.
About 20% had endometriosis. About
16% had polycystic ovarian syndrome.
About 6% had diabetes. And about
64% of the patients have a history of childbirth,
and about two-thirds of them resided in urban areas.
And in the ART cohorts, about 63%
received two or two-plus cycles of ART.
And as you can see here, breast cancer occurred
in 1,774 women in the
ART cohort and 1,581 women
in the non-ART cohort.
And ovarian cancer occurred in 235
women in the ART cohort and 161
women in the non-ART cohort. For endometrial cancer,
it occurs in 261 patients in the ART
cohort and 252 women in the non-ART
cohort.
The forest plots here show the results of our primary
analysis.
As you can see here that ART exposure was associated
with modest but statistically significant higher
risk of breast cancer and ovarian cancer, but not
endometrial cancer.
You can also see here that endometriosis serves
as an independent risk factor for breast cancer,
ovarian cancer, and endometrial cancer.
And polycystic ovarian syndrome and diabetes serve as
independent risk factors for endometrial cancer.
And childbirth significantly reduced the risk
for ovarian cancer and endometrial cancer, but not
breast cancer. In contrast, it
slightly increased the risk for breast cancer.
And as current understanding and current knowledge and a lot of
prior studies suggested that
endometriosis and polycystic ovarian syndrome are risk
factors for infertility and endometrial cancer,
as well ovarian cancer, we performed further analysis by
excluding patients with a history of endometriosis or
polycystic ovarian syndrome.
So you can see the tables here.
For the endometriosis-negative subgroup, you can see
that ART still serves as a risk factor for breast
cancer and ovarian cancer, but not endometrial cancer.
And the PCOS negative subgroup, again,
you can see that ART still serves as the
risk factor for breast cancer, ovarian cancer, but not
endometrial cancer.
And when we excluded all patients who have a history of
endometriosis or polycystic ovarian
syndromeYou can see here again, ART
continue to serve as a risk factor for breast
cancer and ovarian cancer, but not endometrial cancer.
So with those data, we can say that
the data support our result of primary analysis.
That is, ART was associated with increased risk
of breast and ovarian cancers.
So with all those data, we can say that ART was
associated with modest but statistically significant higher
risk of breast cancer and ovarian cancers, but not with
endometrial cancer.
And we can say that our findings support counseling about breast
cancer and ovarian cancer risk and guideline-based screening for
women considering or receiving ART.
Thank you for your attention. I'll happy to take questions.
Go ahead.
Great talk. Thank you. I'm curious if you looked at
subgroup differences among women who went through
ART but did not give birth.
Yes. So we actually stratified by childbirth.
So I didn't show the data here because of the
interest of time.
For women who have childbirth, we can see that childbirth
indeed
lower the risk for cancer, but ART
still is a risk factor
for ovarian and breast cancer. But if you have childbirth,
yes, the risk is lower than if you did not have childbirth.
Would you consider adjusting for family history, previous breast
biopsy, or other risk factors, at least for breast cancer?
Yeah, this is a great question, and this is indeed the
limitation. So in our data set, we do
not have records for
family history for breast cancer or breastfeeding.
Or BMI, maybe for endometrial.
No. We don't have that.
I'm not sure obesity is a major problem in Taiwan.
But maybe. Well, another question is that
median age is 47, so which is quite
high. The median age of your population at
ART was 47, was-
Oh, so for that, that is the mean age of
maternal age at the date of data cutoff.
So the data cutoff was December 31st,
2022.
Okay.
And each patient enter the cohort in different times, and the longest
follow-up period was up to 22 years.
Okay. So age 47 is not the age at ART.
It's-
No.
Ah, okay.
Uh-huh.
Because it sounded very late, and I wonder how
representative it would be of external populations. Okay.
Uh-huh.
And going back to age, it looked like one of your inclusion
criteria was women 40 years and older.
Mm-hmm.
Why the cutoff at 40, as reproductive issues can happen in the
30s as well?
So
for the criteria, 40 to 70 is the age at the
data cutoff. So-
Mm.
So
on the date of December 31st, 2022,
this woman has to be 40 to 70.
So we have-
So it's retrospective, yeah.
Yeah, it's retrospective.
Everything is-- It's not a prospective cohort-
Yeah.
... it's a retrospective cohort. Yeah.
So we want everybody stand on the same line at the data cutoff date,
and then look back, and to match the identical
individuals, and then follow prospectively.
So
your initial time is not the time at ART.
Our initial time is the time of ART.
Okay. And for the controls, what is the initial time for the
controls, then?
So for the initial time is the individual--
This is a very good question.
Sorry. Just to understand better.
The index date-
Yeah
... for the ART group is the date of first ART.
Yeah.
And then ART matched the subject,
that is the subject who have
matched characteristics, just as I mentioned,
such as comorbidities-
Okay
... and something like that. And at the same day,
the patient had the same age as these
ART subject. So the start date is the
date of the first ART. That'll be the
date for this matched-
Okay
... subject.
Thank you very much.
If we go back to the-- I think we're out of time, but yes, on the method slide
where it said age 40, then age 40 needed to be when they
had their first cycle of ART?
No. Age 40?
Yes. Here. Females age 40-
Yeah
... to 70 years.
So the-
No, it's in
2022. Yeah.
So it's on the end of 2022,
everybody has to be 40-
Ah, I see. Okay
... to 70.
Perhaps one recommendation. I think usually we think about the inclusion
criteria and the setting of the age when the individual-
And under the notes
... underwent the intervention, rather than at the time of the data cutoff.
Because one could easily look at this and say, "Wow, this is a much older
population than we anticipate giving childbirth."
Yeah.
But still very important data, and thank you.
Thank you.
Anyway, very interesting. Thank you. Thank you very much.
So our next speakeris Dr.
Shubhankur Sood
from the Global Precision Medicine Translational Research Group in
Heidelberg and the DKFZ in Germany,
talking about developing a real-world clinical genomic platform to deliver
precision oncology in underrepresented populations.
Perfect. Thank you. I'm, first of all, grateful to the
AACR committee and to the chair for allowing the opportunity to
present some of our latest work here.
I am Shubhankur Sood from the German Cancer Research Institute,
and I'm excited to
discuss with you how we have gone about creating a clinical genomics
platform, which from its inception is
global and with the idea of actually including the
underrepresented population as one of its major pillars.
These are my disclosures.
So,
just for all of us to be on the same page when we talk about precision
oncology, I think it's important for us to understand how
big of a disparity there is. So with this graph,
I'm trying to show you, with deeper the red, the higher the cancer mortality.
This is data from the WHO, and you clearly see that
certain regions and certain countries are far more
affected than the other, and superimposed on it as a normalized
between these three regions out of 100.
I'm showing you the amount of data in the last decade that
these regions have contributed to cancer
research, clinical trials, and also some of the new
therapies out there. I'm showing the India
subcontinent as an example, but this clearly holds true for other regions as
well, and this has become now
one of the major stepping stones for us to come up with therapies which are
truly global in nature and not just an intention
towards it. So,
this is not just theoretical information.
I want to quickly also point out what we realized in our initial
understanding of how big the problem is.
We looked at, in this case, FDA datasets, and we realized
about only 14% of the world
is represented in the clinical trials
datasets. And this kind of a bias
at the FDA level also then translates into huge cost and
which leads to a lot of cancer therapies not,
again,
going to the populations where the necessity is even higher.
And I've given you only a couple of examples here, but this is an exhaustive
list with multiple drugs having gone into clinical trials
or certain which have not because of these limitations.
Again, I think especially with the AACR
this year and the
influx of new AI models, I think it's equally important to also
highlight the bias, which at least we see supercharging
this
inequity where we start with data sets which probably do not
represent the globe, or if they do, they represent the globe in a certain
discriminatory
data view, and that essentially leads to the models which we use and
essentially grow and build on. So these
are some of the limitations of our current research and
clinical applications, which got us thinking of how
us as a research center would like to approach this.
So that's essentially one of the major driving visions for us, where we
want to really enable real-world clinical genomics, and
for us, I think, with thinking hard and long on this
problem, we realized there are essentially three major
pillars. So the first being clinical solutions, where we would
like our current technologies to be able to contribute to
the clinical usefulness in some of the underrepresented populations.
And in doing that, create data sets which probably leads to research and
innovation, both at a global scale but in a population-informed manner,
and hence essentially being a grassroots solution.
We also see this to be a problem where you need
education and training for it to be a sustainable approach, and we are
happy that's one of the major pillars which we as a
research institute, but also as an ecosystem which
we're trying to create, I would like to contribute towards.
So,
putting this idea into practice. So our first model, essentially
first use case, was a partnership between India and
Germany for a precision oncology framework, where we realized it
actually fits in very well with complementary strengths of both the two
countries. When you look at Germany, there's substantial cancer
mortality with about 10% projected increase, but we do
have through the Cancer Research Institute based in Heidelberg, a
network of
cancer centers across the country with multi-modal
genomics being delivered at a clinical practice, and this is an integrated
framework.
What we also do see
in Germany,
having this clinical framework can then be translated, in this case,
to India, where the cancer mortality is considerably higher, and there is
supposed to be even sharper increase in the proportion of
cancer cases. So we see there's a clear necessity.
Plus, there's a huge and diverse population, which can really be
important for us to be able to understand as this first use
case.
So,
starting first with what we've already established in Germany.
This is a very quick overview of what our colleagues at the Cancer Research
Institute over the past decade have been working towards essentially developing a
precision oncology pipeline from end to end.
Our major workhorse here for the molecular profiling is the whole genome
sequencing. Again, tumor matched plus transcriptome.
We've been able to do this at a clinical level with more than 8,000
cancer patients. And this being a national
pipeline has really led to more than
85% clinical information and new clinical
trials.So,
yeah, wanted to quickly show you a little data here, and this is published, so I'm
going to keep it short, but essentially wanted to point out here,
with the progressive survival, especially in the molecule-informed therapy,
there's clearly a benefit of using such an end-to-end
platform.
Further, you also see that in more than 20 tumor types,
we can apply this approach, again, showing that this isn't just
few tumor entities which benefit.
There's clear value addition for more than a few tumor entities, and this becomes
even more important when we want to scale this approach.
So in addition to having a molecule-informed
pipeline, we've also been working,
and this has recently now also been published, at a more knowledge
connector-based level, implying using not just molecular information but also
external knowledge bases and clinical data to come up with therapy
recommendations. So bridging the gap from coming up with newer
diagnosis to actual clinically actionable therapy,
in this case, use case of a molecular tumor board.
So our question now was essentially, "Well, we have these pipelines.
How do you integrate this for a real-world use case
in this application for India?" So what we've done is essentially
focused on the prospective clinical genomic cohort in India, not
just molecular data, but also histopathology and imaging, with a
target cohort of 10,000 cancer patient over the next couple of years.
And essentially use the reference datasets we have in Germany, to
create what we call data lakes, essentially, to power some of
our AI tools and some of our technologies to be able to
deliver some of these solutions to the patients in India.
So, I wanted to show you a couple of examples. Let me see if this works. It does.
So here what you see is an example of our
use case in breast cancer. Essentially, we have a cancer patient India
with HER2 positive breast cancer, with more than five plus
years of clinical history. Again,
multicenter and longitudinal, which we had to come up with a
solution of being able to integrate all of that datasets, which is essentially one
of the major pillars of being able to deliver real-world solutions is
how do you start digesting this data at source?
So that's something we spend a lot of time and energy developing and
implementing. What this has also led is essentially a
multiparametric analysis, again, over the cloud at the
source. So for us to be able to do this at a huge scale,
that's not where we wanted to stop, not just at the diagnosis.
We also wanted to help with the clinical reporting and decision support.
So we've also gone ahead and used the decision
support tools we generated along with the international molecular tumor boards
to really help with clinical decision support for these patients.
That was a technical example of how technically this is feasible.
You can actually use some of the technologies we have in Germany,
for an Indian use case, for a local ecosystem.
But equally important was what's the clinical utility.
In this case, I'm showing you how
head and neck cancer, even though considered rare in Germany, is one of the major
incidents in India, one of the major cancer mortalities.
And the question was, "Can our approach of adding WGS really benefit the
current standard of care, which is final?" And the short answer is yes,
both in the biomarkers, which we find, but also on the
evidence level of the treatment approaches you can provide to the patients.
So this is, I think, very interesting for us to build further, have more
datasets, try to see what new biology we can discover, and that's
something we are equally excited to build.
Furthermore, we realize it's not just
the N of one for each patient that we like to create
value for. We also want to do
further research and development, and that's why we're equally excited to
build a disease dataset, essentially being able to integrate
not just the DNA, RNA, but also the imaging and clinical data
longitudinally. And this kind of reference datasets
help us further understand the biological insights, but also the
clinical translation, and hopefully now ask questions which are more
globally relevant at a population level.
So that's something we have been actively working towards, building the dataset and
then being able to answer some of these questions.
Finally, one of the other aspects we realized, being a
research center, to be able to decimate some of these
technologies to a broader application.
We recently actually started a spinoff,
by the Cancer Research Institute and High STEM, where our approach is
essentially twofold. One, to partner with the local ecosystem.
We see it's absolutely essential for the local hospital diagnostic
lab government agencies to partake in this change, and equally
importantly, get the international layer to the
drawing board to start asking questions which you probably didn't
because you didn't have access to some of the data at the grassroot level.
So I think this is one of the applications we've been building towards,
and we're happy to further collaborate to bring this to other countries and other
regions, to really
use some of the datasets for a common good.
So with that, I'd like to quickly summarize.
I think I've hopefully tried to explain to you, convince you in
parts that
the platform we're building here is to provide precision oncology at a
global scale. And this initiative needs to start with
the region in mind and the problems you have to solve for them, rather than
trying to superimpose a model you've already developed and try to force fit
it for a certain geography. So I think this, with an
Indian example, we've seen clear scientific value where we address this
huge data imbalance. We see the genetic diversity.
In this case, India could add to our current databaseHelps us further
stratify and understand our patients even in Germany.
So it's a win-win situation.
Furthermore, we see there's clinical value and a lot of technical value,
with a model like ours, which is modular, and you can add new
AI layers and build on it rather than a static system, which essentially you need
to go back to the drawing board every time to build a new system to be able to
propagate that further.
So,
just food for thought, I think, very
close to our mission is this year's AHCR's, theme of
precision, partnership, purpose, where what we
firmly believe, especially when you talk about precision medicine, it needs to be a
global standard, not just a regional privilege.
And I think, with the audience here, at AHCR and specifically in the room,
I'm happy to see multi-stakeholder partnership as one of the defining pillars
for this change. And I think,
in conclusion, I see the main purpose of equitable and
inclusive precision and our use case has clearly shown its value for
everybody, not just one or the other population.
So with that, I'd like to thank, particularly High STEM and the
Cancer Research Institute, our partners and collaborators, particularly
Professor Trump for his unwavering support, and most
importantly, the patients, because their courage motivates us to keep
going and building further. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So very interesting. Open for questions. Go ahead.
Dr. Sood, thank you very much for a very informative presentation.
Just on the topic of under-representation of data from the lower
middle-income countries and global databases.
I just want to see if you can comment on the fact that for certain LMIC
countries,
data could actually be underreported, right?
Because, my family is Filipino in origin and
some of them are very poor. They don't even go to see the doctor, and some of them
who've passed away now may not have known that they had cancer.
So just want to see if you can comment on that as far as underreporting
is concerned.
Fantastic question. First and foremost, I'm happy that that's a discussion which
we've started now. I think that was one of the major problems we had initially not
discussing that the data you see isn't truly
representative because there's a lot we're just missing and is underreported.
So I can tell you from our example, we've tried
to really look into the Indian setting, especially in our case, for
head and neck cancer, for example, breast cancer, HER2 positive.
The amount reported is actually underrepresenting the current
population by sheer access to some of those resources.
So our approach has been to start using the currently existing
data, using whole genome sequencing, which we are building on, and then try to add
smaller, more cost-efficient panels, et cetera, to be able to really
identify that population which we've missed.
So we see this, we are one drop in the ocean, so there's
clearly certainly more effort required both from the government and
international committees like the one we are at, to push this, to be able
to get everybody connected, so to say.
Thank you.
Hello. Great talk.
I am curious. So this could be a very rich
resource to apply and to advance precision
oncology, and I am curious, can you share your
experience
when you recruit patients, when you built your data set, and
also about the financial aspect and the data ownership?
Well, that's a lot of questions. I'll try to address as many of-
As quickly as possible.
As many as possible. So,
yes. Absolutely. First question, yes, we see this as a
huge resource.
The datasets we've been trying to build, we are essentially trying to introduce
more whole genome sequencing
in
Indian subcontinent, starting in India, but expanding outwards.
That's essentially a major kind of datasets we're trying to create.
We do understand, especially in developing countries, the let's
say genomics and essentially the ethical and the governance aspect of it
might not be similar to mature countries like in
Europe or the US in this example.
So we've been working with the government to establish some of those
governance around those, where we clearly see the ownership, for example, should be
similar like in Europe and America with the patients.
It needs to be consent based. So that architecture we are
in the process of building. And I think that's one of the major
pillars where we see
the involvement of multiple stakeholders is absolutely
essential in addressing those. And I have
forgotten the other half of the question.
Oh, I'm afraid we're out of time.
Okay.
Okay. Sure. I can talk with you later.
Certainly.
Great. Thank you.
My pleasure.
Thank you very much.
So next, we will move to our final speaker, Dr.
Harshit Sahe from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center in
New York, presenting on the pan-cancer landscape of alternative
lengthening of telomeres revealed by machine learning analysis of
clinical sequencing data.
Good afternoon, everyone. So I'll be talking about telomere maintenance in
cancer, and this work was co-led by me and Bill Diplas
in the Sphere and Morris Labs at Memorial Sloan Kettering.
And so some introduction. So in normal cells, telomeres shorten
progressively when the cells divide, and as a result of that, eventually
these cells reach a limit on how far they can divide.
However, cancer cells proliferate indefinitely, and to do
this, they have to maintain their telomeres as they divide, and this is a
universal hallmark of cancer cells.
So how do cancer cells do this? Well, around 85% to
90% of tumors do this by reactivating telomerase,
and these tumors are marked by, for example, TERT promoter mutations and
gene amplifications.However, a small subset of
around 10% to 15% of tumors do this by a
second pathway known as the alternative lengthening of telomeres, or
ALT, and this will be the focus of my talk today.
And this pathway is usually exclusive with telomerase base
reactivation and is marked by truncating mutations in ATRX and
DAX.
And so despite being rarer, ALT is highly clinically relevant,
and this is because it has high prevalence in several aggressive cancer types.
It also shows distinct clinical prognosis, seen here, for example, in
pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors.
And it has several targetable vulnerabilities that are under study
for targeting these ALT-positive tumors.
And so despite this, and despite interest in this pathway, it
has been challenging to use it clinically, and the reasons for
that are that the canonical marker, which is ATRX or DAX loss,
is neither necessary or sufficient for ALT.
Also, detecting ALT requires specialized non-clinical assays.
And prognostic effects of ALT are tumor type specific and hard to
generalize.
And so we thought that enabling large-scale detection
of ALT in real world clinical cohorts could solve this
problem by helping us identify novel genetic
drivers, enabling patient stratification for clinical analysis,
and also assessing prevalence and prognosis in several tumor types.
And so to do this, we turn to MSK-IMPACT, which is a platform that
has been routinely clinically sequencing patients at MSK for a panel
of 300 to 500 genes for over a decade now.
And thanks to
that amount of time, this clinical cohort is much larger than
any other cancer cohort used for such analysis.
And specifically for our case, it also has a lot of samples with
alterations in the key TMM genes that might be involved in telomere
maintenance.
And so we asked if we could use this cohort to study ALT,
and we began by
leveraging this assay that enables detection of biomarkers of this
pathway from patient DNA. And so we took this
assay and applied it to around 700 samples in the IMPACT
cohort. And shown here are the results of that with
the y-axis showing high ALT activity samples.
And so as you can see, ATRX and DAX truncations are consistently
associated with high activity in ALT.
But there is this population of tumors where this loss
is not needed for ALT activation, as well as this population of
truncated tumors that show no ALT activity in
this assay.
And so while these results were intriguing, this assay is still
limited in
the amount of samples it can be applied to.
And so we asked if we could leverage other ways to identify ALT
in the larger cohort.
And so to do that, we turned into this insight that has been used to detect
ALT in sequencing reads from whole genome samples, which is
that ALT typically has longer and heterogeneous telomeres.
But as most of you here would know, in a targeted sequencing panel, you're
covering a much smaller region of the genome, so only around 300 to 500
genes.
However, due to experimental noise, a large number of reads can fall
in these off-target regions are scattered across the genome.
And when we began this analysis, we saw that around 30% of reads in our
cohort were off target. And in a typical workflow, these are
typically discarded since those are not where mutations are called.
But we found that these often contain these telomeric sequences that could be used
to classify ALT.
And so we leveraged these off-target reads and
using our C-circle labels, built an ensemble
classifier that was trained to detect ALT purely from these
low coverage discarded reads. And we calibrated our model so that
its classifier score was a probability that
was calibrated to the presence of C-circle activities.
And what we saw was that this model, despite relying on these routinely discarded
reads, performed pretty robustly.
So shown here are the ROC and PRC curves for this
classification task on held out test data.
And what we then were able to do is take this model and apply it to the
entire cohort of 78,000 tumors that I was talking about,
returning for each tumor a probability of ALT.
And so,
I'll now talk about what we found when we did that.
And so shown here are predictions for the entire set of tumors that we were
looking at. And what I've done here is colored in red tumor types
where other published work has identified high ALT
prevalence. And so despite ALT being pretty rare, our model
picks up the tumor types that it's highly prevalent
in seemingly correctly. And this alignment also
holds on the subtype level for specific
tumor types where ALT is high.
And what's new here, however, is that because of the size of our cohort,
we're able to get these estimates for a very large number of tumor
types.
We can also look at how these predictions are stratified by
genetics. And again, as expected, ATRX DAX truncations are
enriched for ALT activity, but there is still this population
of negative predicted truncated tumors.
And when we stratified these again by literature evidence, we saw that these
truncations occur in tumor types where ALT has either not been
reported or been rare. But what we see is that these truncations
do occur in those tumors, but our model predicts no ALT
activity.
However, the other interesting thing we noticed was that in tumor
types that are commonly associated with ALT, there is a
significant population of missense mutations and
non-truncated tumors that also show ALT activity.
And so we asked if we could identify what novel genes might be
associated with theseWith
these in these tumors.
And very briefly, when we take genetic features and try
to predict our labels, what we see here is
just an important score for each gene, again, in all samples,
suggesting that our model is learning the correct associations.
But what we can do is look at these in these wild type tumors and assess
novel genes such as RB1 and POT1, which are both known to have roles
in telomeric biology.
So very briefly, I'll introduce some clinical questions we've been
aiming to answer,
and
one of this is this context specific association with prognosis that
ALT has been known to see. And when we look at
gliomas and uterine sarcomas, two tumor types with high ALT
activity stratified by our predicted labels, we recover
this pattern previously reported in smaller studies where ALT positive
gliomas have overall better survival,
despite having worse survival in other tumor types such as
sarcomas.
But what our predictions let us do is study these in tumor types
that have been understudied for this.
So for example, in our cohort for osteosarcomas, we see
slightly better survival for ALT positive tumors.
And interestingly, this effect is the opposite of what we see in ATRX/DAXX
loss tumors, suggesting that the prognostic effects of these two might not be
related.
We can also leverage work done by others on the Impact cohort.
For example, using radiology reports on these patients that lets you
decide prognosis and progression metastasis.
And when we look at, for example, for soft tissue sarcomas, we find that ALT
high tumors have a much faster metastasis rate
than ALT low tumors. Again, consistent with the notion of these tumors
and sarcomas being more aggressive.
And so to summarize, I showed you how routinely discarded reads
could be used to identify this rare but clinically relevant
telomere maintenance mechanism,
and doing this for a large cohort enabled us to get pan-cancer ALT
prevalence, novel genetic associations, and prognostic associations
of ALT.
And I'd like to acknowledge members of the Morrison Sphere Lab
who were included in this work, but as well as all
the core facilities at MSK, the MSK Impact team, and all the
patients whose samples were used for this study,
and the chairs for this wonderful session, all of you for being here, and with
that, I'll take any questions.
Thank you for presenting these classifiers and innovative
use of an existing data set.
As you look at these kind of hypothesis generating questions, what would be the
next experimental steps for you to confirm?
And what do you view as the kind of long-term pipeline into a clinical setting?
That's a great question. So I think
we're basically interested in this from both ways.
So, with the Sphere Lab, they're interested in the biology of this, so we're
following up on some of the gene hits that we get in these
samples that activate ALT without the canonical truncation
that I talked about.
And from a clinical standpoint, what we're interested in doing is assessing
if the clinical associations we see can be studied either in relevant cell
line models or in smaller stratified patient cohorts
to follow up. As far as the clinical utility is concerned, I think
the main task there is to get sort of an
indication of what calibration, for example, is
relevant for certain questions. So for example, for a clinical trial,
you might want slightly different cutoffs for how
confident a model is for stratifying this patient based on what
the tumor type and what the drug target is.
And so, that is, I think, the next step, which is to look at
some of these clinical questions and assess what is the best way of
drawing a line to where the model should be used. Yeah.
How do you see the clinical utility practically in five
years from now?
Randomized trial to demonstrate?
Yeah. So I think that one of the biggest limitations has been that there's
some drug targets that have been identified for ALT, but
there aren't active trials with them, and one of the
challenges is just getting patients with these tumor types.
And so I think especially for the rare tumor types, such as
osteosarcomas and some other rare cancers where ALT has high
prevalence, using these models, just because we have
these patients coming into the clinic regularly at MSK and other cancer centers
might be useful.
Would it be reproducible through different technologies and
platforms and-
So I-
... WGS versus panel and...
Yeah. So I think that you can
do more targeted assays,
such as the C circle assay that I mentioned, which is to confirm
or validate specific samples. But if you're interested in larger cohort
studies, then I think modeling would be the way to go.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Great talk again.
Thank you.
So it was our last speaker
that we thank a lot.
And we will now turn to Dr.
Shivani Sood to
give us the final conclusion and discussion of this session.
Good afternoon. It has been a privilege to chair this session titled "From Real
World Data to Evidence-Based Medicine" with Dr.
De La Loge.
These are my disclosures.
So we have heard seven presentations that speak to the breadth of what
real world data can deliver.
Real world data is health information collected outside clinical
trials from electronic health records, registries, claims
databases, and genomic platforms.Real-world
evidence is what we generate when we analyze that data with
scientific rigor.
Both have the potential to move the bar clinically.
For example, the FDA has formally recognized that real-world
evidence can complement, or even in select cases,
substitute for traditional trial evidence, as codified in the
21st Century Cures Act of 2016, which was designed
to accelerate medical product development and bring new
innovations and advances faster and more
efficiently to the patients who need them.
Real-world evidence has already contributed to oncology drug
approvals and label expansions. In the device space, more
than 100 medical device submissions between 2020 and
2024 incorporated real-world evidence, with
over half of them supporting regulatory approval.
On the safety side, the Sentinel Initiative and post-marketing surveillance
programs have used real-world data to inform labeling
updates.
So when we consider that roughly 40% of cancer
patients would be ineligible for the trials that
define their treatment, and that very few patients have access and
resources to participate in clinical trials, reliance on
real-world data is not optional, it is essential.
The seven studies in this session show us how real-world
data can range from hypothesis generating to
confirmation of our clinical intuitions.
So here are our key takeaways.
Dr. Longshore and colleagues conducted a
large real-world retrospective analysis of molecular
testing data over 10 years from a commercial diagnostics
laboratory to characterize variant level frequencies
of actionable biomarkers in non-small cell lung cancer.
Dr. Tran and colleagues characterized the lung cancer in
never smokers' histologic landscape, and for non-mucinous
adenocarcinoma, evaluated the prognostic value of
the International Association for the Study of Lung Cancer
grade
system and additional histologic features in large data sets.
Dr. Shaw and colleagues performed a large real-world outcome
analysis of HER2-amplified microsatellite stable
metastatic colorectal cancer, comparing TDxd with
standard chemotherapy.
Dr. Himbert and colleagues conducted a cohort analysis using the
Veterans Health Administration data to compare cancer outcomes
among patients who received ARBs versus ACE inhibitors.
Dr. Lin and colleagues leveraged national data from Taiwan to
identify associations between reproductive technology and the
risk of breast, ovarian, and endometrial cancers.
Dr. Suth and colleagues shared innovative work being done to address the
global imbalance in genomic evidence generation through
a real-world clinical genomics platform, integrating
prospective clinico-genomic data from India with validated
precision oncology infrastructure from Germany.
Dr. Sahay and colleagues used the MSK Impact clinical cohort
to train classifiers for detecting alternative lengthening of telomeres,
a telomere maintenance mechanism observed in several aggressive
cancer types.
So here we see several unifying themes.
First, scale unlocks discovery.
350,000 liquid biopsies, nearly 80,000 tumors
analyzed for alternative lengthening of telomeres, 2.6
million veterans. These sample sizes facilitate the
statistical power needed to detect buried
signals.
Second, extracting new knowledge from existing
data.
For example, repurposing discarded off-target sequencing reads,
using EMR-based databases, validating a grading system
in never smokers using archival slides.
Indeed, the next breakthrough may already be in
our data sets, waiting for the right question.
Third, equity as a scientific
imperative. For example, using liquid biopsies to
democratize access to molecular profiling across variable
settings, developing a platform generating
multi-omics data for patients in India.
These studies exemplify how real-world data
supports precision oncology, as we cannot be precise
if we are simply extrapolating data based on a narrow
population in well-resourced settings.
And fourth, but most important, bridging biology and the
bedside. Each study generated findings with direct
clinical relevance. How do we assess tumor mutation status
in community-based settings? Are there more subtle implications in
antihypertensive selection? Should cancer screening be
informed by fertility treatment?
Is there use or utility to earlier use of targeted
therapies compared to chemotherapy?
The path from question to observation to next
action is shorter than ever.
Now, while we celebrate these many successes, the field
does have key limitations, as many of our presenters highlighted
in their slides. These include, but are not limited to,
confounding and selection bias.
Observational data cannot fully replicate
randomization. Unmeasured confounders persist despite
tools including propensity matching.
Second, data quality and completeness.
Missing data, inconsistent coding, variable follow-up across
institutions and registries does impact results.
Arcing back to the slides that Dr. Dalal showed, as the saying goes, garbage
in, garbage out. No amount of statistics can compensate for poor
data quality.Third, generalizability
trade-offs. Large-scale data does not guarantee
representativeness. Database populations may still
skew towards certain health systems and groups.
Next, association, not causation. This is a critical one.
Real-world data generates hypotheses but rarely proves
causality. Ensuring that real-world data is fit for purpose
or validation in prospective trials when appropriate remains
essential. And last, reproducibility challenges.
Heterogeneous data sources, variable definitions, and analytic choices
can limit reproducibility across studies.
So where do we go from here?
The path forward requires moving from association
to actionable evidence. A key element here
is consistent methodological rigor to facilitate
the generation of evidence that is of the quality fit for the
purpose of moving the needle.
Several bodies have provided guidance and frameworks to facilitate.
For example, the EORTC, as shown here, has outlined a
hierarchy prioritizing pragmatic trials when feasible
and target trial emulation when not.
In the US, the FDA is partnering with institutions for the ENCORE
project. This is a project designed to emulate 12 randomized
controlled trials in four oncology specialized electronic health
databases across four different cancer indications.
Specifically, non-small cell lung cancer, breast cancer, colorectal cancer,
and multiple myeloma.
ENCORE will place a special emphasis on systematic
evaluation of fitness of data in relation to the study
design and statistical analysis for a particular research question
and pre-registration of study protocols prior to
initiation and analysis. The FDA's Advancing
Real World Evidence program has established new regulatory pathways, and
other bodies such as ASCO have called for improved data quality
and transparent
reporting.
Finally,
integrating multi-omics with AI, expanding global
representation, and embedding real-world evidence into guidelines
and decision support will close the loop between data
generation, analysis in the modern era, and patient
care.
We are indeed eager to see where the data and researchers leading these efforts
will take us next. And with that, this is the conclusion
of our session, and we thank you for your participation.
Great talk.
Thank you.
Wow. Brilliant.
Amazing.
Thanks to all your pointers. That's very helpful.
Well, I think we stayed on time.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
They were cute.
You could tell some were nervous.
Oh, yes.
Especially her. She was very...
I kept forgetting my hands were going all the time.
She made it.
She must be proud.
And good engagement from the audience.
It was quite interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, we had like 40 people.
I counted at some point.
I truly wouldn't be that many but-
Right.
But you know better than just this room.
No, yes.
I've seen sessions with lower.
Better than finishing.
And the last guy.
Yeah.
Just over here.